bonjour à tous l'iphone 8 va arriver
d'ici quelques jours
il est temps de faire une petite mise au
point pour voir quelles sont les rumeurs
les plus plausibles celle qu'ils
arriveront probablement jamais et qu
elles sont aussi les choses que
j'aimerais voir sur ce futur iphone je
suis monsieur heureux j'ai une chaîne
qui parle de stratégie youtube pour vous
aider à progresser tout au long de votre
chemin sur youtube mais également des
produits l'influencé du high tech
je suis un grand passionné de high-tech
et forcément on s'intéresse à la high
tech on s'intéresse aux smartphones et
on s'intéresse à apple et aux futurs
iphone 8
qu'est-ce que cet iphone oui il va nous
proposer qu'est-ce qu'il va y avoir à
l'intérieur c'est ce qu'on va regarder
tout de suite tout d'abord cela il faut
lui devrait un petit peu changé d'un
point de vue esthétique fini comme sur
l'iphone 7 par exemple les grandes
parties avec les grands bords on aura
plus de bord ici et plus de bord ici
plus de bouton home physique
fini également à l'arrière à d'avoir à
priori un objectif simple ici il doit y
avoir une refonte d'un point de vue
esthétique de ce produit on devrait se
retrouver avec un téléphone avec un
écran qui devrait occuper toute la
partie du smartphone et avoir un dos en
verre alors pourquoi comment déjà un
écran beaucoup plus grand
on devrait avoir un écran comme celui ci
en termes de dimensions devraient avoir
les mêmes dimensions que l'iphone 7 13 8
cm 6,7 cm et 0,7 de profondeur si vous
regardez angers c'est un bout de papier
l'iphone n'est pas sorti je n'ai pas de
prototype j'aimerais beaucoup il ya
d'ailleurs de youtube heurts qui ont eu
des des impressions 3d côté fait des
imprimantes 3d
je n'en ai pas dont japon tenté de mon
bout de carton mais que c'est quand même
son petit effet alors si on compare
globalement c'est pas tout à fait le
même ratio il ya quelques millimètres
d'écart mais si vous regardez par
rapport à un iphone sept voiliers que
l'écran serait quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus grand l'écran
serait beaucoup plus grand pour la même
dimension
à savoir que ce sera un iphone c'est que
vous avez un écran en 4,7 pouces et sur
un iphone 7 plus 5,5 pouces sur l'iphone
nuit vous devriez avoir un écran en 5,8
pouces c'est à dire que vous feriez
rentrée un écran plus grand que l'iphone
c'est plus dans le châssis d'un iphone 7
vous auriez donc un écran beaucoup plus
grand des vidéos beaucoup plus sympa à
regarder ici juste une petite place pour
le haut parleur et pour les capteurs qui
serait directement intégrés dessous le
bouton home disparaîtrait on devrait
avoir a priori un bouton home virtuel
qu'on doit pouvoir retrouver ici
une rumeur fait aussi état d'un bouton
sur le côté qui vous permettra de vous
permettrez de déverrouiller avec votre
empreinte digitale
a priori pas de capteur derrière comme
sur les galaxies ou comme sur le dernier
alger entre autres l'écran devrait
changer ce serait aussi la fin des
écrans lcd qu'on retrouve sur les
iphones traditionnels
on devrait avoir un écran oled alors les
écrans oled pour les avoir vues tournées
notamment sur le dernier lgv 30 jeu
assuré que c'est un vrai régal
les contrastes sont saisissants les
couleurs sont incroyables vous prenez
vraiment le l'écran la lumière en pleine
gueule pardonnez moi l'expression mais
c'est vraiment saisissant au dos on
devrait passer effectivement du capteur
simple avec le flash à un capteur double
alors à la verticale on sait pas
pourquoi
probablement pour des questions de
technologie ou leur juste pour
différencier d'un point de vue
esthétique par rapport aux concurrents
toujours est il que vous devriez avoir
votre double capteur avec le flash au
milieu une dalle en verre à l'arrière
pour permettre la recharge par induction
car oui les nouveaux iphone devrait se
recharger par induction on conserverait
également une prise lightning
normalement ici ce qui vous permettrait
d'utiliser vos accessoires donc
probablement une recharge par lightning
mais surtout par induction qui devrait
être compatible avec tous les systèmes
de recharge à induction actuelle on
pense notamment aux voitures qui sont
les plus récentes vous n'avez plus qu'à
poser votre téléphone dessus qui se
rechargent c'est un gain de temps c'est
vraiment très très appréciable du coup
pour déverrouiller vous devriez vous
vous retrouvez avec une reconnaissance
faciale au niveau de l'appareil photo
devant un appareil photo avec un tout
nouveau capteur qui permettra
effectivement d'avoir une reconnaissance
3d biométrique
lorsque vous aurez reçu smartphones face
à vous même si vous regardez en haut en
bas à droite à gauche il ne se
déverrouille rep ah par contre dès lors
que vous
le regarde et lui il se déroulerait ce
qui fait que il ya une vraie
reconnaissance de la position des yeux
par rapport à la caméra et une présence
connaissance biométrique côté processeur
on devrait retrouver le nouveau
processeur à 11 d'apple permettrait
effectivement d'avoir de nouvelles
performances et notamment pour intégrer
la réalité augmentée réalité augmentée
d'ailleurs qui est déjà présent au sein
du nouveau ios 11 côté stockage on
devrait bien évidemment avoir un
appareil en 64 giga 128 giga mais a
priori on pourrait même monter jusqu'à
512 gia
si toutefois vous avez des besoins
énormes en terme de vidéo en musique
voire même en photo vous devriez être
comblés avec ce nouvel iphone niveau
prix on s'attendre à un prix qui est
même supérieure à 1000 euros
je vous laisse imaginer le prix d'une
version en 512 giga je pense qu'à ce
moment il va falloir casser la tirelire
pour pouvoir acquérir ce nouveau produit
voilà ce qu'on peut dire sur cet iphone
8 l'iphone anniversaire pour les dix ans
à priori devrait aussi y avoir deux
autres modèles qui devraient sortir on
ne connaît pas la dénomination exacte ce
serait soit 1 7 s et 1,7 et plus soit
effectivement un iphone 8 et 8 plus mais
si on les appellent l'iphone 8 et 8 plus
le produit homogène vous parlez ne
s'appellerait pas l'iphone 8 mai
l'iphone anniversaire l'iphone édition
voire même l'iphone x moi j'ai quatre
souhait principaux a formulé le tout
premier c'est effectivement la réalité
augmentée on a vu dans ios 11
la réalité augmentée est prévu donc a
priori on devrait la retrouver on sait
qu'on l'a sur la nouvelle génération des
ipad donc a priori on devrait la voir
aussi sur ce nouvel iphone deuxième
souhait c'est la réalité virtuelle la
réalité virtuelle est de plus en plus
présente très appréciable j'ai encore pu
jouer la réalité virtuelle de microsoft
et quelques jours d'ailleurs on va en
parler très prochainement c'est vraiment
top j'ai hâte qu'on put abord un casque
avec un iphone pouvoir le brancher
dessus pouvoir en profiter
c'est un souhait a priori ce ne sera pas
présent dans cette nouvelle version de
l'iphone mais a priori dans une version
ultérieure troisième souhait mais je
pense que la masse au dessus c'est le
retour de la prise jack
j'utilise un micro rod que je branche
dans mon téléphone pour les prises de
sons extérieurs lorsque je me déplacer
je fais quelque chose de très très 10
et malheureusement sur l'iphone cette la
prise jack a disparu et là je suis
extrêmement triste parce que c'était
vraiment un outil d'autres que je ne
puis plus utilisés alors effectivement
vous me direz il existe un adaptateur
sur le port lightning avec une prise
jack
sauf que lorsque vous posez votre
smartphone sur un pied vous avez un truc
qui se baladent c'est un trafic en
termes de prises de sons c'est beaucoup
moins directionnelle et c'est beaucoup
moins efficace donc je regrette vraiment
que la disparition du plan de chaque
quatrième point qui pour moi est
probablement le plus important ce serait
d'avoir une caméra à l'avant d'une
excellente qualité en tant que youtube
heures quand on se filme on veut
toujours voir parce que ce qu'on est en
train de filmer sauf que les caméras
quand toujours la meilleure qualité sont
toujours situées à l'arrière ce qui fait
que lorsque vous filmez à l'arrière de
cette manière là vous filmez à la veuve
vous ne voyez pas que tu es en train de
filmer vous n'avez pas votre moniteur
ce qui fait que si vous avez une caméra
à l'avant qui est d'une excellente
qualité
vous avez effectivement autre caméra
pour filmer et la fonction monitoring
ici ça serait vraiment quelque chose de
très très important j'ai vu des
smartphones lors de l'ifa qui le propose
et j'aimerais vraiment que apple fasse
également sa gosier une excellente
caméra à l'arrière mais aussi une
excellente caméra à l'avant
voilà un petit peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur ce nouvel iphone il sera
annoncé très prochainement
mardi 12 septembre et ses qualités parce
qu'on va en parler en long en large et
en travers
vous vous dites moi tout ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire dit mme aussi
quels sont vos souhaits ce cas des
choses des fonctionnalités que vous
aimeriez voir qu'est-ce que vous
souhaiteriez retrouver sur ce smartphone
vous mettez tout ça on en discute
ensemble je vous invite à vous abonner à
ma chaîne passe pour encore plus
deux vidéos équipements sur la stratégie
youtube pour vous aider à réussir mais
également des produits du high tech dans
un petit peu le lien entre tout ça parce
que les produits high tech on en a
besoin aussi pour réussir sur youtube
abonnez vous à ma chaîne c'est des
questions vous pouvez contacter sur
twitter @ monsieur re et avec le hashtag
hast monsieur heureux quant à moi je
restais pardonner cette vidéo et je vous
dis à très très très bientôt pour de
nouvelles vidéos
salut
[Musique]